oui je voudrais vous dire je voudrais
vous dire un mot qui ne touche pas au
logement qui a été extrêmement traité
est très bien traitée par notamment par
mon ami claude et par tout le monde et
vous dire un mot de des magouilles de
madame hidalgo
s'agissant de la réorganisation des
arrondissements dernier conseil de paris
semble-t-il là elle est en train
d'agiter l'idée qu' il faudrait
regrouper les arrondissements parce
qu'il ya une action trop petit et donc
elle envisage une grande réforme dit
elle des statuts de la ville la fusion
naturellement avec le département mais
ça c'est pas très difficile mais le
regroupement des arrondissements de deux
remarques très bref j'ai très court la
première remarque c'est que qui vivent
dans un grand arrondissement comme le
15ème ou dans le plus petit comme le
premier qui est dans ma circonscription
je sais que les parisiens sont tous très
attachés alors on dispense ça fait
partie de leur identité
donc c'est très compliqué d'aller
expliquer à des gens de paris c'est un
assemblage de village les gens ils se
reconnaissent dans leur arrondissement
de leur expliquer que les
arrondissements on disparaît tous être
regroupés de façon baroque mais très
calculée de la part de madame hidalgo
croyez moi avec plein d'arrière pensées
politiques et électorales c'est un vrai
sujet je crois et je laisse suggérer
depuis longtemps depuis longtemps ça
fait j'ai même déposé des propositions
de loi dans ce sens il faut qu'à paris
nous sortions de cette anomalie qui
consiste à perdre l'élection municipale
alors que nous sommes majoritaires en
voix
il faut qu'à paris
il faut qu'à paris le maire soit le
maire de tous les parisiens
même si par ailleurs dans chaque
arrondissement on peut aussi élire un
maire d'arrondissement qui soit de
couleur différente
on peut parfaitement imaginer que le
même jour le parisien ils votent pour
deux listes la liste du maire de paris
avec ses son équipe à lui
et puis au niveau de son arrondissement
l'équipe locale d'arrondissement
ce qui permettrait de réduire la taille
du conseil de paris de donner aux maires
élus une majorité forte et donc de
pouvoir gouverner l'ensemble de la
capitale tout en donnant à chaque maire
d'arrondissement avec des pouvoirs
accrus
une proximité tout aussi fort avec ses
habitants ça c'est la proposition que
j'ai fait est que je souhaite que nous
développions tous ensemble puisque
madame hidalgo souhaite bidouiller le
statut de paris autant en profiter pour
que nous nous revenions à cette idée qui
me paraît indispensable et qui
cohérentes avec ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure sur la sécurité thème que là
aussi j'ai défendues depuis les
attentats de 2001 quand quand quant à
new york la halle la ville de new york a
été attaqué le mais rares le maire était
compétent sur les pouvoirs de police
ce n'est pas le cas à paris et donc
l'élection suffrage universel du maire
les pouvoirs de police du maire une
vraie vraie politique municipale ça doit
être possible et c'est ça que je
souhaites que nous fassions et je lui ai
dit tout à l'heure à frédéric péchenard
ces derniers jours et également à
nathalie donc j'espère que nous
avancerons dans ce domaine merci votre
attention